[Música]
hace unos meses sacamos este vídeo en el
que hablábamos del milagro económico de
singapur mucha gente considera este país
un modelo a seguir y lo cierto es que
hay que reconocerles que muy poquito
tiempo han sido capaces de pasar de ser
un pueblo de pescadores por debajo del
umbral de la pobreza a ser uno de los
tres países más ricos del planeta pero
esperado un momento porque singapur está
muy lejos de ser ese paraíso de
libertades que muchos piensan
el chicle o la goma de mascar está
terminantemente prohibida en este país
es más si te pillan importando chicle a
singapur te puede caer una multa de
hasta 100 mil dólares o incluso dos años
de cárcel por supuesto si la policía te
pilla escupiendo chicle por la calle la
multa asciende a los 700 dólares
[Música]
esto porque pues porque el gobierno de
singapur entiende que el chicle es algo
muy poco higiénico muy poco saludable
que ensucia las ciudades y que además
puede crear grandes problemas si la
gente los coloca en las cerraduras o en
los aparatos electrónicos pero esto es
sólo un ejemplo hoy vamos a ver la otra
cara de singapur y creedme hay para rato
lo primero que tenemos que entender a la
hora de hablar de singapur es que es el
resultado del sueño de un hombre lee
kuan yu el auténtico padre de la patria
lee kuan yew fue el artífice de la
independencia de este país y además el
presidente del mismo durante 31 años
nunca has tenido un momento en el que
pensaras que singapur era demasiado
autoritaria
lowell mi trabajo es mantener el camino
del país y garantizar que todo el mundo
tiene una vida decente y educación y
ahora son los más educados de todo el
este de asia luego lo vi ser lee kuan yu
quería construir una sociedad utópica
donde todo el mundo fuera rico estuviera
bien educado fuera respetuoso con los
demás y por supuesto no tuviera ningún
vicio y eso explica cosas como esta
[Música]
censura en singapur normalmente a los
dictadores les gusta limitar la libertad
de expresión para poder oprimir a una
minoría religiosa o consolidar sus
privilegios y los de su familia en
arabia saudi persiguen a todos aquellos
que ofendan al islam pero no protegen
igualmente al resto de religiones lo
mismo ocurre en guinea ecuatorial donde
no puedes insultar a su dictador teodoro
obiang pero sí que puedes insultar a
otros políticos extranjeros o incluso de
la oposición sin embargo en singapur la
censura existe para garantizar que nadie
se salte los cánones de la corrección
política no olvidéis que en este país de
5 millones de habitantes tenemos a todas
las razas incluidas hay europeos chinos
malayos etcétera pero nosotros no
tenemos inestabilidad tenemos a
distintas razas conviviendo
patrióticamente diferentes religiones
pero no en choques no sólo eso es que
además en singapur no se puede ofender a
ninguna religión da igual que sea el
cristianismo el islam el budismo o la
cienciología y por supuesto tampoco se
puede criticar algo
ni a la sagrada figura de lee kuan yu
vamos y pasarás seis semanas en la
cárcel y pagará una multa tras ser
declarado culpable de haber herido
sentimientos religiosos y algunos
pensaréis que esta falta de libertad de
expresión fomenta que haya mucha
corrupción en el gobierno de singapur
verdad lo cierto es que ser un político
corrupto es un mal negocio en este país
es más la policía no necesita pruebas
determinantes para meterte en la cárcel
si te pillan metiendo la mano en la caja
y los castigos incluyen cinco años de
cárcel multas millonarias y por supuesto
latigazos de eso vamos a hablar en un
par de minutos ahora bien esta falta de
libertad de expresión sí que explica por
qué el lee kuan yu pudo mantenerse en el
poder durante más de 30 años y su
partido político el partido de la acción
popular tiene más del 70% de los escaños
del parlamento es más incluso después de
su muerte está terminantemente prohibido
criticar ofender o siquiera hacer
chistes sobre la figura de nuestro amigo
el igual
entonces y fustazos
si esto que está sonando ahora mismo es
parálisis permanente un grupo mítico
español de los años 80 y es que no me he
podido evitar ponerlo para hablar de
cosas como estas
dos alemanes sentenciados a agotamiento
y nueve meses de prisión por hacer un
graffiti en un vagón de tren
efectivamente singapur es uno de los
pocos países del mundo donde existen
penas de azotamiento es decir no es que
los policías maltraten a los reclusos es
que en el propio código penal
singapurense está estipulada la pena por
azotes propinados con una vara así que
si te condenan por vandalismo por
ejemplo te pueden caer 6 789 azotes o
los que sean y no os creáis que es una
práctica anecdótica sólo en el año 2012
se aplicó a este tipo de castigo más de
2200 veces y por supuesto el código
penal de singapur también incluye la
pena de muerte y a diferencia de otros
países como eeuu que también tiene pena
capital en distintas regiones en esta
ciudad de estado se puede aplicar a
crímenes como por ejemplo el
narcotráfico cuando está en una muerte
es incluso suave porque los traficantes
están matando familias enteras todos los
días durante años cada vez que una hija
se vuelve un adicto pero ojo antes de
criticarlo tenemos que reconocer que
todos los países de la región aplican
las mismas penas contra los
narcotraficantes desde indonesia malasia
filipinas y por supuesto china pero
esperad porque todavía hay más
libertades personales como os decía al
principio
singapur parece seguir al pie de la
letra la filosofía de jóvenes cuando
decía eso de que el hombre es un lobo
para el hombre y necesita restricciones
para no caer en los vicios por esta
razón la venta de pornografía está
prohibida en singapur aunque gracias a
internet sus ciudadanos ya pueden
visitar páginas de contenido para
adultos pero no sólo es la forma grafía
también hablamos de otras cosas como el
consumo de chicle o goma de mascar que
está considerado un hábito muy poco
higiénico y por tanto está prohibido
pero si esto os parece poco tenemos
prohibiciones aún más absurdas como la
de estar desnudo en tu propia casa por
lo que te pueden caer multas de hasta
dos mil dólares y os preguntaréis cómo
es posible que un país que persigue
tanto el vicio sea famoso por tener dos
de los casinos más grandes del mundo
parece un poco raro que un país que es
tan estricto con otras cosas permita que
sus ciudadanos se dejen sus ahorros
jugando a la ruleta verdad lo cierto es
que miles de ciudadanos vienen a
singapur cada año a jugar al blackjack
la ruleta rusa o el póker vale vale vale
ya sé que he metido la pata en singapur
no se juega a la ruleta rusa solamente
juegan a la ruleta normal pero sus
ciudadanos es decir los naturales de
singapur tienen que pagar un impuesto
especial si quieren entrar en estos
casinos es decir que el gobierno protege
a sus propios ciudadanos de sí mismos
pero esperad un momento porque hay un
área donde singapur es sorprendentemente
abierto algo así como una válvula de
escape para los vicios
singapurenses si estoy hablando de la
prostitución que a diferencia de otros
países como suecia francia o españa en
singapur está reconocida y regulada
singapur cuenta con más de 6000
prostitutas y digo los registrados estos
profesionales del sexo están obligados a
hacerse chequeos médicos de forma
periódica además la ley de prostitución
singapurense prohíbe expresamente el
proxenetismo
es decir que si tú quieres puedes
practicar el oficio pero no puedes
montar tu propio burdel y tener a
trabajadores sexuales en tu plantilla y
tampoco se te permite ofrecer tus
servicios en la calle de forma explícita
a no ser que estés en ese barrio donde
se concentran todos los lupanares de la
ciudad hablamos del distrito de gay land
se puede tratar muy
y todo puede ser
por cierto que esto tan afrodisíaco que
está sonando es la música de rick un
cantante compositor y guitarrista
colombiano que nos ha enviado su música
si os gusta podéis encontrar más en los
links de la descripción
pero esperad un momento porque pese a
todas estas regulaciones singapur no ha
conseguido evitar que existan muchísimos
casos de prostitución ilegal que es la
que se alimenta de todas estas redes de
trata de blancas no tenemos cifras
exactas sobre el número de inmigrantes
que han sido explotados sexualmente pero
sabemos que existen y la prueba es que
en el año 2014 el gobierno sacó una ley
especial para prevenir este tipo de
casos ha funcionado no ha funcionado
todavía es pronto para decir
en resumen esta falta de libertad es el
precio que pagan los singapurenses para
vivir en esta utopía ahora bien tenemos
que ser justos porque el resto de países
vecinos de singapur está muchísimo más
atrás en lo que a libertades
individuales se refiere en malasia la
homosexualidad es un delito lo mismo
ocurre en indonesia donde por cierto
también tienen penas por azotes y todo
tipo de castigos corporales por no
hablar de que en singapur existe un
imperio de la ley y todo está escrito
negro sobre blanco y en el resto de
países vecinos no está tan claro
y la pregunta es creéis que el régimen
de singapur es sostenible llegará el
momento en el que las autoridades se
verán obligadas a aceptar diversidad de
opiniones y de estilos de vida
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones como
siempre si alguien quiere profundizar
más en este tema encontrará varios links
en la descripción si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
con estas cosas la cas
a mí